what is it then about munson's that has
made this art of the possible maybe
inspire other people to give us awards
but not only that to come and see what
we're doing now
so we've got a science-based target now
the science-based target is that target
where if we all uh reduced our carbon
emissions by that particular amount then
the impact of the humans on the planet
would uh be minimized and that the
temperature wouldn't rise beyond what
what is uh deemed
correct so we've had a
target a 45 reduction in emissions of
scope one and two i guess i'm going to
preach to the converted but if you don't
know what that is that effectively means
our use on site
and we're going to achieve that in 2022
that's actually three years early
our scope 3 scope 3 is everything that
comes into us
and everything then that goes out from
us from the factory we've already
reduced that by 30 by working with the
supply chain and now we're looking for
the next 30
so it's very much uh when you talk about
a target of course the target gets you
there but that has been an absolute step
change
in our emissions performance
and the emissions performance in fact if
you looked at it people talk about the
whinge about government targets the
government target was actually only 18
in that same time so we've actually said
well that wasn't good enough it wasn't
going to get us to where we needed to be
to be serious about having a
science-based target so
setting that target did indeed open our
eyes how did we get there well i
designed the world's first carbon
calculator for malt for scopes one two
three
in fact my very first version of it i
was about 10 pounds i couldn't develop
one in two weeks and i did and then
farmers weekly told me it was the third
most used carbon calculator in the uk
which made me rather nervous
but i think what it showed was that
people wanted simplicity my calculator
had nine questions the other one
available had 120 and people even like
me who was a sustainability professional
so people called me at that time
um
i couldn't understand some of those
questions and i think that was that was
indicative of why i wasn't particularly
working
so our strategy is to be carbon neutral
by 2050 we're going to be carbon neutral
long before 2050 as i say we'll hit our
science-based target in 2022.
we will of course set another one um we
won't just just stay there
what was it that we found when we set
our carbon uh footprint first of all we
found that it didn't really matter whose
model you use people were out there at
the time i was getting a lot of
opposition in the supply chain whenever
i stood up and you're going back to 2004
2006 when i was first talking about
these sort of things i was even faced
with a boycott when i went to germany to
speak about this people said we're going
to get up and walk out if you mentioned
carbon footprint
why was it they were very nervous about
the the types of data that was coming
out i said look here's a couple of
models the top three things are the top
three that means that we know the areas
we need to be working in we need to be
working on gas and electricity on our
sites no great surprise but the thing
that did surprise us was that the impact
of barley growing was so high we just
didn't know that until we mapped the
carbon footprint and that led then to
people in the supply chain for bali
saying so it's our fault i said when did
i ever use the word fault i want to know
what i can do to work with you so that
your embedded carbon is lowering my
product and although it took us four
years to eventually find a way of
talking to them
after that four years we actually
released a press release between us and
we've got arms around each other i mean
my goodness you know how can you go that
just shows
the way that you can go through this
journey just just put up with the flack
and just
keep saying that this is what we want to
do we want to find out how using the
whole supply chain can make these
changes because we certainly couldn't
make it by ourselves now the thing what
i like about this is that when people
say which model should you be using
everyone says that you should be paying
many many tens of thousands of pounds
for models but we found that the
difference between the models is only
about six percent now i like flicking
the figure if you've heard me before
that means i'm 94 certain that this
figure is correct now how often are you
94 certain of what you do i wish i was
but that means that we just move on so
yes i'm saying that we can reduce our
carbon footprint
do i want to argue whether we've reduced
it by 60 by 61.5 by 58. i don't care the
fact is that i've then reduced it by
about 60
when i know for a fact that other people
in the supply chain have sat there since
2004 and have reduced by nothing and
that's what i think the art of the
possible move on and don't worry too
much about accuracy
when we split that carbon footprint up
for barley we found that a lot of it was
to do with a nitrogen fertilizer the
nitrogen fertilizer manufacturers were
about to reduce part of their process by
90 percent
so we became one of the best publicity
agents by saying if you're going to
produce fertilizer at the same price
but actually then with a 40 by the time
they'd finished a 40 reduction we're
going to say that our customers must buy
your fertilizer
and by doing that we got a 30 reduction
in our embedded carbon
the next thing is the nitro nitrous
oxide emissions from the soil
and that 20 years ago seemed really
really difficult to get people to talk
about it
we're at the point now where not only do
we think we can control that but we can
actually turn that into a negative
that was you know i'd have been locked
up 20 years ago if i'd said that but now
it's actually possible
it's very important of course then to
extend so that we um don't just talk
about carbon and we've been we've
extended to taking the sustainable
development goals in the interest of
time i won't go through all of those
um i'm going to go through the race race
to zero because all of those things that
we're doing
they
really do in my mind align very nicely
with this government target and many
people said you know
aren't they crazy to set a target of 78
reduction by 2035
the initiatives that we've got in place
if you look at our 2010 emissions we're
going to be post 60 by 2022 so i don't
think that it's out of line with what we
need to do i also don't think it's out
of line with what's possible now
the way that we've approached this is
then and i'm really sorry i can't people
with the presentations this afternoon
i'm hoping i'm going to be able to read
these afterwards we use this model of
people profit and planet the triple
bottom line
if you go into the boardroom there is
still the feeling that this stuff is
tree hugging it is absolutely not one of
the things i did last year was to
i know i do three days a week for
monsoons i have my own consultancy
called vault doctor
and that's really been helping
businesses to understand
that these words are not just words you
can use them and integrate them into
your business systems and you can you
can describe it for the board in terms
of risk
so this is de-risking their business if
they look for energy saving and they
look for alternate fuels
it happens to benefit the planet as well
and there are still too many executives
out there that don't engage in
environmental concerns
but just explain it to them in a
different way and you get to the same
point
and certainly in terms of people we are
now finding that more and more people
are saying because you've got a credible
sustainable performance
you're open about what you know and
you're open about what you don't know
i'm no i can't see any point being any
other way we want to come and work for
you and we want to stay and work for you
and our customers are saying the same
thing so 35 of our business at present
is
we they have told us they have chosen us
because we have a sustainability record
which is verifiable
it's open and we've got data which we
can prove so it's really important
um so when we're talking about the
sustainable goals we put specific words
next to it if i don't suspect if you can
read that you're doing extremely well
i'm struggling to read it on here
but go to our website and download our
sustainability sustainability report for
this year and you can read the details
we put behind it
now that science-based target is a great
thing
over a thousand companies have signed up
to saying that they think science-based
targets should drive the way a business
works but only fifty percent have
actually set a target so my challenge is
if you've ever if you've done that
if you're in the camper thinking it
might be a good idea we'll sign up if
you're in the camp of having signed up
and thinking i can't understand the
figures well they're not that difficult
really you've seen the sort of accuracy
that you need
why should you have a science-based
target from a business perspective well
63
of company executives say that it drives
innovation it does
i i've been sitting there probably for
20 years thinking that the the
originally the deck target and the the
you know the
uh climate uh levy targets of 18 percent
were really really difficult and then i
looked and said well the science based
target wants me to save
more than 50 percent well that's just
silly isn't it
it made me look at alternatives and i
found those alternatives
35
will tell you that it increases your
resilience against future legislation
absolutely does because you're ready for
it and you can talk
with uh with uh
enthusiasm when you go to uh the
government department we went into what
was dec before they wanted to give us a
17 extra target and we said so where are
these initiatives coming from which
things that we haven't put in place are
you telling us we should
they said
well we haven't got any so i said so
it's a zero percent target they said
come on we can't go back to treasury
with that how about one so we said how
about a half and we shook hands and that
was the way we found that it's good to
be really open because you can get a
benefit
from being open about your data
and definitely 55 percent of executives
say it gains a competitive advantage it
absolutely does
now when you're explaining carbon
footprint to people here's one from the
greenhouse gas protocol
what is it about a carbon footprint that
shouldn't scare you
well if you have a look at the figures
here when
i look at this i i get an invoice for my
gas use which is 34 and an invoice for
my electricity use which is six percent
so therefore i'm a hundred percent
accurate
on 40 of that data
move on when i look at the 60 which
comes from the malting barley which
comes in to me
i was struggling 20 years ago because
there wasn't a calculator having
developed that calculator and then
there's about three different variations
of that calculator since i know i'm now
within six percent
accuracy on that so that's pretty high
so for over 90 percent of my omissions
i know i'm pretty accurate so therefore
i don't have to worry about the thing
which your inbox will be filled with
day in day out of consultants not like
me consultants try to charge you 30 40
000 pounds and frightening the life out
of you saying you need to calculate your
scope 3 when it leaves your factory you
do
but what do i do
i don't do that i use the financial
model which is available which predicts
your scope three indirect missions
downstream
i don't care if i'm 100 inaccurate that
i won't be but i'm only for three
percent is it gonna be three percent or
six do i care no i don't i'm happy that
i know the ninety percent
uh and that's why when we developed this
carbon footprint calculator here as you
can see there it was very simple
in fact it was nine questions i did
better than the ten questions i was set
it helped farmers understand it was
about fertilizer use it wasn't about
going to buy a new tractor which might
have been fun but it wasn't going to
save you much in terms of carbon
footprint
and that then meant that we could
specify to our supply chain that they
needed to use a baited nitrogen
fertilizer and we got that 30 lower
barley carbon footprint
i'll quickly go through this because
it's been mentioned this morning but
my uh view here is that when we talk
about legislation legislation has driven
i think it was 44 mentioned this morning
a 30th so called it 38 to 44 reduction
in emissions in in that time period
it's estimated by uh reports that 40 of
this has come through legislation what
does that tell me
that tells me that 60 percent of the
time business thought it was the right
thing to do
so
that again is don't wait for the
legislation make to make you do it
sixty percent of the time business
should be able to see for itself it's
the right thing to do
and when the report comes out that we
see net zero it's really not helpful for
the many businesses that came out and
you see you saw it on social media
calling it the not zero report
immediately knocking it and saying you
can't do this you can't do this you
can't do this there's lots you can't do
but hopefully i've seen showing you in a
couple of examples there's a lot that
you can do and you should be doing it
now when we get very techy you can of
course report this data out there and
you can put some pretty big figures on
how we've reduced scope one two and
three
you can tell people exactly how it is
which part of your supply chain scope
three comes from but the biggest thing
to me
is what are you doing to get it down so
if i if i sat there back in 2007 and
with my our emissions for monsoons at 50
odd thousand and said it was going to
come down to just under 10 between 6 and
10 i would have thought you know you
really
you know you can be locked up you've
been a straight jacket but we found ways
to do it with existing technology
so the first one we put in was an
anaerobic digestion plant which took our
waste because we have a brewery
effectively uh if we fermented it we'd
be uh we'd be as big as green king
but so we don't ferment we just make
malt extract so it just shows the sort
of size we are
previously that waste was going off site
now it's being used to generate 14 it's
actually 16 last year of our electricity
on site
that means that
we also don't have the the waste sludge
materials that used to come from taking
that waste off site
we won the award that year for the best
anaerobic digestion plant in the uk
but it took us four years to persuade
the environment agency
that we could use the waste the material
that came off it wasn't waste and could
go back onto farms they actually shut
their offices because they couldn't cope
with people trying to do this sort of
thing
don't be put off if that's your
experience we ended up having a
brilliant visit from the national
technical officer from the environment
agency who helped us see how we could
get through their mass
of regulations and then get this out
there
we then
installed biomass this is not the
where that's been in the paper i think
it's just this week where some of the
big power stations are bringing you from
argentina or mexico or wherever they're
bringing you from this was waste
material available in yorkshire next to
our plant it was wood that was chipped
and put on the forest floor
we took that chip material and we put it
in a biomass boiler we saved 90 percent
of the emissions relative to to natural
gas
we've done the same thing down at stone
market and again we're saving 90 percent
of the electricity there
in the interesting time i'm going to let
you see this afterwards i'm going to
skip past this this one because that's
just proof of the pudding that the uh
that farmers actually like this stuff as
well
the point is though in terms of the art
of the possible read this one as well in
your in your when you've got more time
the world resources institute now are
all are saying that we can reduce by 73
percent
our emissions in agriculture right now
how do they say we're going to do it
well plant-based diets
better yield reduced
fermentation
restoration of peatlands etc
what they're saying is that you end up
with a very little amount to offset
there are too many businesses now who
are starting looking to offset
it's never the right thing to use
somebody else's good work to offset the
bad things that you're doing that is the
worst sort of offsetting the oxford
principles which came out last year said
that you should be looking for more
ethical
sorts of offsetting offsetting for us is
that we've got to the point now where
you can have a sustainable product
within your supply chain that can
generate you the credits
we've validated that by reference to the
sustainable agriculture platform and
again in the interest of time as we're
trying to cut down i will just very
quickly go through that to say that
there is an international standard
uh which is available which is enables
businesses to
describe the sustainability performance
of your supply chain we were the first
monster in the world to uh declare that
we have 100 sustainable malt 100
sustainable barley uh our competitors
said well we don't believe it so we got
audited and the auditor said they're
correct so you know again this art of
the possible don't be put off by people
say that you can't do it or you know you
can't possibly be that good
there are some pictures which you can
look at later or in terms of the
anaerobic digestion plant yes it was a
six year investment payback five years
longer than our three years that we
needed so
you know it was it was a difficult one
perhaps initially to get past the board
but it saved all those 3000 less tanker
movements and produces a quality organic
fertilizer
the biomass plant at bridlington just to
underline the point
we didn't need to put our money into
that we used money from an external
supply company because we wanted to
spend our money on other capital
projects
but to underline the points as well i
think is that you're not alone when
you're looking at these savings
so
the fertilizer which i said has already
been reduced to 40
already is likely to be carbon zero
within five years with the technology
that they're doing that will reduce our
embedded carbon so we're not alone on it
the barley growing that we said is the
biggest part of our carbon footprint
already we know that by putting in a
cover crop which is things like clover
or veg
even for 30 days between the crops you
think you'd never get any carbon um
removal from the atmosphere it works and
it's we and it
proved we're going to have carbon
negative barley we've got it this year
actually but i'm not not showing you the
details i'm saying within five years
that will mean we will have carbon
credits available in our supply chain
which is a more ethical way in my way of
saying this is this is real carbon
you're taking more carbon out of the
atmosphere than you are then balancing
uh when you've grown it so you
neutralize the amount that you've grown
and take some more out as well
who wouldn't want to buy those credits
we've got brewers and distillers and
monsters falling over themselves to want
to buy those credits from farmers
however when we look at our supply chain
we only have 48 looking at heat
generation for electricity eight percent
considering hydrogen and still only 48
thinking about carbon zero by 2050
really honestly i'd say to the industry
it's got to get over itself and move the
electricity industry is doing great
things and decarbonizing by 2035 and 64
heat decarbonization is possible
this is our latest one this is the one
where if i don't stick to time i'll be
in great trouble because i'll miss the
train to london and hopefully we're
going to win the award for this as
innovation another 60
reduction uh it is finished it isn't a
skeleton like that if you walk if you
drive past stone market you'll see it so
almost there i managed to recover nine
minutes of my presentation so you can
have your lunch on time this is what we
say to people now this is what we think
you should be doing as the art of the
possible look at the energy efficiency
yes
measure it in detail map the operations
so that you know exactly where your
carbon hot spots are
go out and set a science-based target
it's dead easy though i said it in 2010
because they give you lots of easy
spreadsheets now don't be put off by it
and then look for specific and
measurable change it's there
it's there with existing technology it's
there supported sometimes by grants or
sometimes not
most of the work that we've done has not
been supported by grants i would say
because we're an sma we're this is this
is my wins we're just the wrong size to
get grants with 300 so we tend to not to
use the grant system uh but i love the
look at the grants that you were saying
about that the heat network i i think
it's a brilliant brilliant move i'm very
very keen to see that and i'm interested
to see how
businesses with waste heat can link into
those those heat and heat networks it
will be easier for us than trying to put
electricity out on the grid because the
grids had it hasn't it so there we go
drive your business strategy to address
people profit and planet and i think
although we're 20 years late starting we
will get there and we might overshoot to
start with but we've got the capability
of bringing that climate change impact
back
thank you
[Applause]
you